et maintenant voir les camions par les
musiciens
oui c'est bien dit il
à
bonsoir comment ça va bien
joey starr j'y vis des pigeons louvain
jean jacques debout pierre arditi qui
arrive du théâtre ça va oui ça s'est
bien passé à mal
ils ont applaudi et la fin pas mal à ça
c'est bien ouais ça c'est bien c'est
bien le nom ouais c'est que je rencontre
des gens que ma mère aubry aurait voulu
rencontrer michel 15 mois néanmoins
gilles vacants non entrés en jeu les
entre copains tous les deux fait garde
gérard louvin pierre arditi frégate son
image non est ce que tu peux donner une
carte de bons clients à pierre arditi
parce que c'est vraiment le bon client
type vous savez pierre que la chaîne
fait des études sur les invités des
émissions pour rendre ça non et alors il
ya une étude qui a été faite sur les
invités de l'émission l'année dernière
vous arrivé largement en tête c'est
marrant c'est effrayant la chaîne fait
car ne manquiez
la chaîne kentzinger les points clés que
d'études nous a transmis ses charme fou
sens de l'humour oui avis sur tout
l'invité idéal
bon voilà l'écouté pas besoin de vous
interviewer les gens sont repartis ravis
mais les gens sont heureux de voir
pierre arditi dénonciation pourrait
faire un gros plan pour mettre les gens
la seule chose qu'ils veulent c'est ce
qu'on peut voir la gueule mon cas c'est
tout oui voilà c'est même pas la peine
de parler les gens voient ça gueule sont
pas seulement voilà voilà très bien là
les gens sont heureux ça vous pourriez
les esprits bisous oued avait déjà c'est
l'amour la paix nulle maintenant je ne
peux plus me trimbaler nulle part et
tout le monde me dit ça il ya un truc
quand même que les gens comprennent pas
bien c'est votre mac sans ces pourris
c'est que les avait déclaré il ya
longtemps bien sûr mais sarkozy je suis
pas complètement contre est-ce que c'est
toujours le cas j'y dis simplement que à
un moment donné sur certains points très
précis d'ailleurs qu'on peut énumérer
ici si vous visiter absolument
ce n'était pas absolument content quand
il supprime la double peine c'est lui
qu'il fait je regrette que la gauche ne
l'ait pas fait avant lui d'accord vous
serez d'accord avec moi et ça fait la
version marine 1
quand il se décide qu'à un moment donné
les mecs qui pensent que la puissance de
leur voiture est inversement
proportionnelle au coefficient de
dilatation de leur type est d'une
certaine manière ça me choque pas
vraiment moi je romps on est on est
et un c'est vrai si ces menus attention
gens comme un non mais sérieux jean
pierre en fait vous allez vous savez
bien que sarkozy qui a fait des trucs
bien effectivement comme la double peine
est ce que par exemple quand il dit il
faut des amendes pour les pétards fumé
un pétard veulent une amende de 10000
balle plus confiscation du portable +
confiscation du sculpteur et c'est sans
doute pas la solution non non sérieux
pouvais pas le suivre là dessus sarkozy
il sort du théâtre il est le premier
truc à faire alors sarkozy dirige
il faut être et avoir quelqu'un qui sort
de ces jeunes je ne suis pas forcément
d'accord mais merci c'est quoi c'est
quoi il a craché ya un peu de tout c'est
mon jeu aujourd'hui
eh bien non même nous emmerder
simplement les règles en premier si on
en juge le conflit israélo-palestinien
30 secondes on t'emmerde rapidement un
nom mais la suppression des prostituées
par exemple est d'accord et la
confiscation des portables pour les
professeurs à la suppression des
prostituées c'est pas comme ça qu'on
peut définir là ils les enlèvent des
quartiers chics parce que ça fait sale
ou alors ils essayent de jeu je pense
qu'ils essayent de de régler le problème
comme y crever schéma singes je me
demande
j'ai encore comme dira omar sharif la
france tu sûr ce mandat d'assurer sur
mais moi si tu n'es pas là sur wii c'est
pas les simples la suppression des
prostituées c'est ça va tenter de nous
de réguler la prostitution ou en plus à
ne faire que que que la prostitution qui
dans certains cas peut être assimilé à
un esclavage
parce qu'un certain nombre de ces jeunes
femmes sont pas forcément d'accord qui
sont leur demande de faire plus tout de
même raisonnablement se poser la
question de savoir si on ne pourrait pas
essayer de voir si on peut pas faire
autrement quand même c'est pas une
question absolument indigne 1
ce qu'est les moyens employés sont bons
je peux pas vraiment répondre mais en
tout cas le fait qu'on se préoccupe du
problème n'est pas en soi une tare très
honnêtement non oui oui vous demander si
vous me posez une question me faire
élire ce que j'ai à vous dire ce que je
pense que j'irai chez vous ou c'est
qu'au début vous défendez un peu et
après vous nous faites 7 sur 7 et
j'adore bien alors qu'approche ne parle
pas de castro parce que lundi c'est à
dire après demain à 20h30
vous êtes au théâtre du rond-point à
l'appel de reporters sans frontières
le lendemain toujours au théâtre du
rond-point donc et du mardi au samedi à
20h30 sur scène avec ariane ascaride
pierre arditi vous interpréter une pièce
qui s'appelle mathilde une pièce de
véronique olmi mise en scène par didier
long
c'est après trois mois de prison suite
un détournement de mineure le garçon
avait 14 ans mathilde qui joué par
ariane ascaride cac 40 ans qui est
écrivain revient chez son mari pierre
s'est jouée par vous que les
cancérologues et elle comprend elle
comprend pas que que le désir et le
plaisir soit puni par la justice
oui pour elle l'acte sexuel c'est
quelque chose de normal c'est quelque
chose de naturel et elle comprend pas
que ce moment était puni de prison
c'est là ce désir de ce jeune homme ou
de ce sept enfants en cours de
fabrication parce que simplement le
désir est là et donc elle cède à cette
tentation c'est puni par la loi ça
s'appelle un détournement de mineure
elle fait trois mois de taule et elle
revient chez elle elle vient récupérer
les affaires et dans ses affaires
évidemment il ya son mari qui s'appelle
pierre qui n'est pas allé la voir en
prison
en vérité on apprend à la fin de la
pièce qu'il est venu qui n'a jamais
réussi à rentrer parce qu'ils pouvaient
pas et en fait elle vient non pas en
état de culpabilité par rapport à ce
qu'elle a vécu
mais elle vit au contraire pour asséner
cet acte là qu'elle revendique comme
quelque chose d'aigus dans sa vie elle
donne beaucoup de détails sur la façon
dont ce jeune garçon de 14 ans lui a
fait l'amour elle dit qu'elle a pris
beaucoup de plaisir qu'elle n'avait
jamais pris autant de plaisir avec un
homme week avec ce jeune garçon de 14
ans vous êtes dur à jouer quand elle lui
dit méfiant délurée lui il me prenait
part derrière non elle ne le dit pas
c'est la mode c'est lamentable
oui ben alors et alors lui il a tout
perdu à cause d'elles a perdu son image
n'a pas de ses amis l'a brisé patients
oui et mais il gagne quelque chose
d'autre un yen quoi il gagne peut-être
quelqu'un qui lui dit que la vie mérite
d'être vécue autrement et pas seulement
dans une sorte de confort endormi d'une
situation confortable où on finit par ne
plus regarder la femme avec laquelle on
vit on finit par la prendre pour une
lampe qu'on allume et connectant au gré
de son de ça donne envie
il gagne ça c'est fondamental ce qu'ils
gagnent c'est mieux que la clientèle
franchement alors